everyone's special - which is another
way of saying no one is fine heavier way
- let's pit you against your family in a
battle to the death to see which special
is the most special of all the specials
it's time for
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the only show that can monologue longer
than a villain in a superhero movie you
sly dog you got me monologue today I'm
covering what's perhaps the most beloved
movie in Pixar's lineup The Incredibles
a film that probably earned that title
because a lot of you watching saw when
you were kids a fact that in retrospect
is a bit alarming considering what the
movies are really about I mean for a
family-friendly film you have a villain
that actually kills people a wife that
suspects that her husband is cheating
and repeated deaths by engine turbine
I've always thought that I had a weird
message to wear buddy
the young fan boy was shunned by his
hero pulls himself up by his bootstraps
to become a billionaire weapons designer
using his genius intellect bait devices
that give him the power of a superhero
himself which honestly is a story arc
that should be praised I gotta say as
the one who felt ostracized throughout
school I totally relate to this guy's
story
he should be a good role model he didn't
give up he used his innate abilities to
get better to get to the position where
he wanted to be instead in this movie
has an inferiority complex and becomes a
sociopathic killer you mean you killed
off real heroes so that you could
pretend oh I'm real and I did it without
your precious gifts here oh so special
powers ate a Pixar I totally feel what
you're going for a year but seriously
intelligence should be a real superpower
but no not the Incredibles and then the
rest of the film treats it like a joke
until he dies a gruesome death and the
heroes are all solidified as the ones
who are born with their innate abilities
clearly this movie believes that some
people are just more super than others
and since you killed off the character I
most relate to movie I'm going full
supervillain and giving you a dose of
your own medicine which super is the
most super in the PAR family who is the
most powerful incredible is it the speed
demon - the quiet psychic violet the
flexible last--i girl or the brute force
of mr. incredible there's also the baby
Jack Jack and the big wild card and the
family whose powers seemed to berry from
setting himself on fire - changing to
different materials you could say he's a
regular
jack-of-all-trades but knowing Oh
Hollywood storytelling works and based
on the fact that the trailers are
already playing all this up it probably
means it's gonna be revealed to be the
most powerful character and Incredibles
- so I'm knocking him out of the
competition in the meantime though place
your bets ladies and gentlemen because
for Incredibles enter one incredible
leaves man I really am starting to sound
like syndrome everyone can be super and
with everyone super no one will be first
things first if you want to talk about
raw strength then you have to talk about
mr. incredible even if Bob Parr is put
on a few pounds since retiring from his
superhero days he is still a hunk of
muscle tossing around cars the same way
most of us would toss around a frisbee
well I guess if he were really throwing
the car like I throw a frisbee it would
mean he would throw the car do it
immediately
karate chop down into the ground and
then roll around on its edge in a
direction completely opposite the thing
I was trying to throw it at just rubbing
the shame in my face as it rolls but
where we really see him start to push
his powers to their limits is when he
halts a train traveling at full speed
right in its tracks to figure out how
much force he needs to stop that train
we need to know two things
a train's deceleration how quickly he
was able to bring that train to a halt
and the trains mass calculating the
trains mass is a bit difficult because
for the brief moments that the train is
actually seen on-screen we never see how
many train cars there are however with a
bit of historical research we can
actually come up with a pretty good
guess on how many train cars there were
how much they weighed and how fast the
train would have to have been moving in
order to determine the mass of each
railway car we can compare it to a
similar railway car in the real world in
the movie we see Bob reading a copy of
the Metro built for view which when you
zoom in real close shows that the second
half of this movie is set in the year
1962 the train stopping scene happens in
the movies opening moments before a 15
years later flash-forward meaning that
that scene with the Train happens in
1947 details also point to the city of
metro Ville being based on Chicago the
font and name of the newspaper make it
look like a tribute to the famous
Chicago Tribune and Chicago is a
metropolitan city that had a booming
during the time period of the movie more
importantly Chicago is also famous for
its l-train short for elevated train
that served as a citywide Rapid Transit
System since 1892 based on the year the
movie takes place and the appearance of
the cars they appear to be the metro
Ville equivalent of the Chicago L trains
steel 5000-series cars which were in
service from 1947 to 1985 we also know
based on historical research that the
5000 series of car had an unloaded
weight of 93 thousand pounds plus
another fourteen thousand six hundred
eighty eight pounds from the weight of
all the passengers inside and yes I
calculated that using the average weight
of a person in 1950 which I might notice
over 20 pounds lighter than the average
weight for a person in the year 2000 hey
you have to account for everything when
it comes to historical accuracy and also
our ever expanding waistline
lastly the length of the Train in the
scene we're able to count eleven visible
railway cars and based on everything we
know about elevated trains in the 1940s
which is a surprisingly large amount
after doing this episode the Train
probably wouldn't be any longer than
that in fact it was uncommon for trains
to be longer than six cars during
commuter hours way back then all of that
gives us a grand total of 1 million one
hundred eighty four thousand five
hundred sixty-eight pounds for the mass
of the train that is 592 ton sister
incredible certainly has a lot of work
to do and work he does he brings that
train from 55 miles per hour to a
screeching halt in just under ten
seconds nine point nine seconds if we
want to be exact do that to a 592 ton
train he'd need to exert a force of one
million three hundred thirty three
thousand Newtons that's the equivalent
of two hundred ninety nine thousand six
hundred seventy pounds of force just for
comparison a study of seventy boxers
found that elite level fighters punch
with an average of 776 pounds of force
with the strongest one ever not being
able to reach 1,300 pounds of force
Bob's punch by comparison would be 230
times stronger than that they don't call
him mr. incredible for nothing and with
that one million three hundred thirty
three thousand newtons of force is our
number
B's next up is Helen Parr aka mom aka
Elastigirl measuring Elastigirl strength
is a bit trickier here since she's not
really about raw strength but rather raw
stretch we never really get to see her
stretched to her limits haha but we do
get to see how flexible her abilities
are but whom Ching alright I'm done with
the puns she has a parachute mode boat
mode hovercraft mode limbo mode shield
offspring from oncoming homing missile
explosion mode up completely shielding
the kids from an explosion of a homing
missile
yikes if her body is able to go full
Groot and repel the force of explosion
like that protecting what's inside it
must be pretty strong and based on her
passing out in the aftermath of the
explosion it's pushing her powers to
their limits so that is the scene we're
gonna analyze but just how strong is she
let's look at the missiles we don't
actually see any other aircraft in the
vicinity so it looks like these are
gonna be surface-to-air missiles
Sam's as opposed to air-to-air missiles
but how powerful are they well when it
comes to surface-to-air missiles the
explosive yield will ultimately depend
on the warhead it's carrying but faster
usually means more powerful I mean the
fastest missiles in the world's our
ICBMs which can reach speeds of over
Mach 15 15 times the speed of sound and
they're usually designed to carry
nuclear warheads scary thought anyway
from the way that the missiles appear to
only barely out speed the plane we can
assume that they're probably moving and
close to the same rate now a typical
commercial jet would be able to hit
speeds of around 600 miles per hour
which is subsonic less than the speed of
sound
not even Mach 1 and we never actually
see Helens plane cross any sound
barriers even as she's trying to avoid
these missiles so that means that the
missiles must be moving pretty slowly
currently the slowest and typically
weakest surface-to-air missiles used by
the US military still hit a speed of
around Mach two and a half
which means I guess syndromes weapons
budget was more focused on building
killer robots and not so much on buying
anti-aircraft missiles information on
the subject is a bit hard to find and
digging around for it has undoubtedly
put me back on top of several government
watch lists there goes my trusted
traveler past I worked a year to get but
out of all the missiles used by the US
military the slowest one is the rim-116
rolling airframe missile Ram a missile
delivering a warhead with an explosive
yield equivalent of forty seven point
two seven nine mega joules or just
around twenty four point nine pounds of
TNT but here's where things get even
more complicated in the scene we see not
one not two but three missiles also
Elastigirl isn't even the first thing
the explosion hits impacting two plane
before even hitting her also also we
have to consider the fact that
Elastigirl isn't at the epicenter of the
explosion when the missiles go off this
all matters because what we think of as
an explosion is basically just a
shockwave that gets weaker and weaker as
it move away from the epicentre and this
drop-off happens exponentially so this
time we're just gonna have to do some
rough estimations if we estimate that
the planes main body or fuselage is 10
centimeters thick aluminum standard for
a typical Boeing aircraft and we use
what we know about the impact strength
of aluminum and estimate elastic girls
distance from the initial explosion at
around 3 meters based on the size and
shape of the cabin and where we see the
missile impact the aircraft the last
girl's body is absorbing a whopping
three million five hundred and ten
thousand pounds of force that is more
than 10 times as much force as we
calculated for mr. incredible to stop
that moving train ladies and gentlemen
we have ourselves a new front runner and
a new definition of girl power and a new
definition of wonderful Cale stop up
next is flash I mean - the speedster in
the family who knows though maybe
Incredibles - will feature reverse -
complete with a yellow costume they
could even completely rip off the flesh
and recreate that time that the flash
was shot with a fat ray kidnapped and
then put on display as the
thousand-pound blunder like some sort of
freak show ah you get it cuz he's obese
now yikes the 60s were a very different
time anyway - demonstrates his
SuperSpeed a lot throughout the movie
but believe it or not
greatest feat of speed that we actually
see him pull off is when he rushes up to
his teacher's desk to place a thumbtack
on the seat and rushes back to his seat
hey dude calm down why you freaking out
it's just a prank bro don't be a prick
about it get it
prick cuz it's a thumbtack anyway the
teacher determined to catch - and the
act has a surveillance camera record the
incident and for a single frame of the
video we see - moving if we assume that
the video is recording at 24 frames per
second as most video cameras did back in
1962 that would mean - was covering a
distance of about 4 meters in just one
twenty-fourth of a second that
translates to a speed of 96 meters per
second or 214 miles per hour but does
that give - the ability to topple his
mother strength earlier we saw mr.
incredible stop a speeding el train but
could he stop - running towards him at
top speed but what's most impressive
about - isn't his speed so much as it is
his acceleration the fastest sports cars
on earth take around 2 seconds to go
from 0 to 60 miles per hour - is able to
go from 0 to 200 14 miles per hour and
stop and then reverse his direction to
get back to his seat again in just a
tiny fraction of a second literally less
than the blink of an eye I ran the
numbers and he's accelerating at a rate
of 9216 meters per second square to
figure out whether dash can actually
topple his father we use one of my
favorite equations of all time on the
show flaw or force equals mass times
acceleration has solved for the force
that - is creating we just found his
acceleration now multiply that by the
average mass for a ten-year-old boy
which is about 72 pounds or 32 point
five kilograms and we find out that
Dash's speedy little legs are generating
299 thousand five hundred Newton's of
thrust the equivalent of 67,000 three
hundred pounds of force which is more
thrust than the engine of a Boeing 747
commercial jetliner with force and speed
like that perhaps his most amazing super
the fact that he's able to get away with
that tack prank he should be causing a
massive wind that sends papers at the
very least flying throughout classroom
anyway at just under 300 thousand
Newtons he's still a million Newtons
away from the raw strength of his father
to match the force of his dad - would
need to put on a few pounds a few
hundred pounds in fact starting with
that 1.3 million Newton threshold we
calculated for dear old dad and dividing
by dashes acceleration he'd need to
weigh in at 141 kilograms or 310 pounds
to tackle his father and way more than
that to punch through his mother's
elasticity 837 pounds or a whopping 380
kilograms
where is a good politically incorrect
flash fat ray when you need it and then
there was one 14 year old violet the
bashful shy girl who wants nothing more
than to reject her superpowers and be
normal or self now she's a tricky one
since her powers aren't physical like
anyone else in her family first the girl
who wants to hide from the world can
appropriately enough turn invisible but
more to our purposes she can create
force fields capable of blocking pretty
much anything and you can't have a force
field without the word force the exact
measurement we've been using to compare
the family we find out about ninety
minutes into the movie that violets
force fields can easily deflect bullets
fusing the performance of a
standard-issue m16 rifle as reference
with a 960 meter per second muzzle
velocity 4.0 two grams mass per bullet
and an estimated stopping distance of
point zero one meters the protective
bubble she's creating is acting with
83,000 288 pounds of force 370 thousand
Newtons that alone puts her ahead of her
brother when it comes to raw strength
but it's not even close to the full
extent of her force fields power you
have more power than you realize don't
think and don't worry if the time comes
you'll know what to do hey saying you're
good in the final battle against
syndromes aamna droid version 10 she
pulls out her strongest force field to
protect - from the giant robot the
omnijoin 10 is a metal sphere with a
hole thickness of about half a meter and
a diameter of about thirty nine point
six meters and we know this by comparing
it to the size of the buildings we see
it next to where it appears to be about
12 stories high accounting for the fact
that omnijoin appears to be mostly
hollow inside the metal part alone would
have a volume of 2,400 two cubic meters
that amount of Steel would have a mass
of 1 point 8 5 times 10 to the 7th
kilograms or 40 million seven hundred
eighty thousand pounds Newton's third
law you know the one that says that
every action has an equal and opposite
reaction tells us that if violet is
supporting an object that weighs 40
million pounds then her force field has
to exert an upward force of 40 million
pounds 181 million three hundred
ninety-eight thousand four hundred
seventy six thousand Newtons that is
nearly 180 times the force that her
father used to stop that train and over
ten times what her mom withstood in the
plane explosions and that's not even
calculating the fact that the robot is
slamming its body into the force field
which means that we have unequivocally
found our strongest incredible it is
dear old dad yeah
the force field would make violet the
strongest incredible by an enormous
margin if it weren't for the fact that
several seconds later when violet passes
out from the effort of holding up that
object we see her father step in to save
the day by lifting up the exact same
omnijoin
and unlike violet he's able to sustain
wait without passing out from the
efforts but that's impossible I hear you
saying I said it too when I was
researching this episode violet has to
be the strongest from our calculations
mr. incredible holding up that robot
takes more than a hundred times the
amount of force that we saw him use to
stop the train at the start of the movie
it's not like he wasn't trying when it
came to stopping that train he knew that
there are a lot of lives at stake and he
barely managed to stop it before it fell
off the rails so how is it that we see
him so much stronger at the end of the
movie especially when we know that this
is after 15 years of him being out of
service as a super well maybe this
heroic feat of strength is chalked up to
the greatest superpower of them all
family gag me cut it out with your
family kumbaya nonsense eeeh hippies but
seriously seeing his children's lives at
stake Bob leaps to their defense and
provides the most monumental
demonstration of strength that we see
throughout the entire movie this is
actually known as hysterical strength
display of extreme strength by humans
beyond what's believed to be normal
usually occurring when people are in
life-and-death situations this is most
commonly associated with stories of
parents lifting vehicles to save their
kids in this case it's Bob Parr lifting
a giant Death droid to save his kids
scientific evidence to prove it is
scarce since as you can imagine it's a
bit hard to test this sort of thing in a
lab hey we're gonna put your kid under a
car go lift it but it is theoretically
possible believed to be tied to the body
increasing adrenaline production in
times of crisis so violet is definitely
number one unless parental instincts
come into play and you know what that
seems like a fitting climax for a movie
that's ultimately more about family
bonds than it is about superpowers
sometimes it takes the family to save
the day and even though Dash and violet
might not be as strong as their dad in a
way they were indirectly responsible for
his greatest feat of strength and that's
Disney Pixar's The Incredibles
your favorite childhood movie with the
moral of you have to be boring special
in order to be special sorry syndrome
your super intelligence and ceaseless
work ethic don't merit you becoming a
super luckily real life doesn't have to
work that way work hard enough and
you can gain yourself super abilities
case-in-point our sponsor for the day
Skillshare an online learning community
with more than 17,000 classes and film
business and writing basically it's all
the skills that you need if you're
thinking of becoming a super youtuber or
really any other modern day career for
that matter finding good reliable and
most importantly useful resources to
teach yourself online is surprisingly
difficult these days I mean you don't
want to fall into the trap of Jake
Paul's how to be a youtuber program
which I kid you not is a real thing that
is really unhelpful
so Skillshare solves that problem by
giving you access to online educators
who really have the skills and want to
help you succeed true story
I had to teach myself everything when I
first started on YouTube and videos like
the ones that I found on Skillshare such
as editing and Premiere Pro for
beginners were the only ways I was able
to get better because there are just
some things that you don't know that you
don't know and honestly these sorts of
videos are how I continue to teach
myself to this day and short classes
like skill shares creative direction for
drone building and DIY cinematography
are helping me learn more skills more
modern skills that allow me to be more
creative in my videos and I know I
talked a lot about video but it's not
just video skills share has everything
from search engine optimization to
website building to mobile app design 3d
printing Microsoft Excel basically it's
all the things that schools should be
teaching you for a job in the modern
workplace but are too far behind the
times to cover
Sokol skills shares their to fill in the
gaps and not only a skill share more
useful than most school courses it's
also way more affordable with an annual
subscription costing less than ten
dollars a month and with this special
offer you can get the first three months
of skill share for just 99 cents it was
originally supposed to be through the
month of January but because you guys
are so special and because this video
happens only come on they're extending
it until February 15 what better gift to
give your loved one for Valentine's Day
than the gift of knowledge GT Live
merged technically but that will be on
sale until next week so
Skillshare sign up at the link that you
see on screen or it's at the top line of
the description skl sh / film theorists
you don't actually know that that is a
crappy URL you're never gonna remember
that Oh sh e I'm gonna remember to put
that up in the URL bar it's in the top
line of the description sign up it's 99
cents to try it for three months teach
yourself a couple new skills like drone
filmmaking which is tough just not gonna
find that stuff anywhere else so
remember friends life isn't like The
Incredibles you can work to achieve what
you want and places like Skillshare are
out there to help again one last time in
crediting the description since not even
super memory will help you remember the
huge block of link text you see on
screen right now but you know what you
can remember the fact that this was all
just a theory
a film theory and commence learning